these days we usually ask cd
hey cd how far is the nearest fuel
station
whenever we ask something to siri the
powerful speech recognition system gets
to work and converts the audio into its
actual form
then is then sent to the apple server
for further processing
and then machine learning algorithms are
run to understand the user's intent
and then finally siri tells you the
answer well this is happening because of
these machine learning algorithms
hey everyone i am ang from simply learn
in this video we will learn what an
algorithm is we will look at what
machine learning is followed by machine
learning types we will continue this
session by understanding how algorithm
work in machine learning followed by
how algorithm work in programming
further we will also see some popular
machine learning algorithms in detail at
last we will end this video by seeing
some hands-on lab with python code
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel hit the
subscribe button and please don't forget
to press the bell icon so you will never
miss any update from simply love so
without any further ado let's begin
in computer programming an algorithm is
a set of well-defined instruction to
solve a particular problem
it takes a bunch of information sources
and deliver the ideal result
most of us must be using snapchat to
apply filters on your faces while making
videos or capturing photographs
but do you know how does snapchat
recognize your face while capturing
videos or photographs and put filters on
it even if there are multiple faces it
applies filter on every face accurately
this became possible with the help of
phase recognition technique which uses
machine learning algorithms to detect
phases and apply required filters on
them
so this is the basic idea of how an
algorithms work
let's move ahead in this video and we
will now discuss how an algorithm work
in machine learning but before that
let's go through what is machine
learning
machine learning is a subpart of
artificial intelligence the art of
making commuters learn and act like
humans by feeding data
and make predictions based on experience
as we saw in previous example when the
data that is how far is the nearest fuel
station
comes in the machine or in our case seri
immediately start analyzing data
and machine accurately makes prediction
and decision based on given data
now that we have an understanding of
what machine learning is let's move
forward and discuss different types of
machine learning
machine learning is classified into
supervised learning unsupervised
learning reinforcement learning
there are two sort of problems in
supervised learning
classification and regression
certain types of machine learning
algorithms fall under the
classifications are decision algorithm k
n algorithm logistic algorithms name
base algorithm support vector machine
algorithm svm however integration types
of machine learning algorithms are
linear regression regression trees
non-linear regression and bayesian
linear regression
now talking about unsupervised learning
there are two sorts of problems in
unsupervised learning clustering and
association algorithms that fall under
clustering problems include
k-means clustering algorithms principal
component analysis algorithms however
algorithms that fall under association
problem are a priori algorithms fp
growth algorithms in reinforcement
learning there are two types positive
reinforcement negative reinforcement
reinforcement learning algorithms are
mainly used in ai applications and
gaming applications
there are certain types of problems
which falls under reinforcement learning
are
q learning
state action reward state action
s-a-r-s-a algorithms
deep q neural network and markov
decision process
after discussing what machine learning
is and its side let's move forward to
see how algorithm work in machine
learning
everyone knows the algorithm is a
step-by-step process to approach a
particular problem
there are numerous examples of algorithm
from figuring out sets of number to
finding roots through maps to showing
data on a screen
let's understand this by using an
example
every algorithm is built on inputs and
outputs google search algorithm is no
different
the input is the search field and the
output is the page of result that
appears when you enter a particular
phrase or keyword also known as serp or
search engine result page
google has a search algorithm so it can
sort results from various website and
provides the user the best result
when you start a search you will see the
search box will attempt to guess what
you are looking for
in order to better understand what the
user is looking for the algorithm is
trying to gather as many as suggestions
from them as possible
the results from the search field that
best matches the query will be ranked
the choose with website will rank and in
what position using more than 200
ranking variables now let's take an
example of coding program and see how
the algorithm works
here we will use a case of counter
program wherein we want to print the
multiplication table of any number
let's take two the algorithm start here
and then it assign a value to a variable
the variable i is having an initial
value of 1.
the system will read the number the
number in case is 2.
now the system has a condition a
condition can now either be true or
false
if the value of i reaches 11 then the
loop will end otherwise
value of i will multiply by the number
the initial value of i is 1 so for the
first time the system output will be 2
now value of i will be increased by 1
according to the loop condition
the system will then move back and check
for the condition again
the new value of i is 2
which is still less than 11 the system
will again print 2 into i which is 2
into 22 on the screen
the new output result will be 4.
the system will keep following the same
procedure repeatedly until the value of
i becomes 11
once the value of i becomes 11
then only the algorithm will terminate
after discussing how an algorithm work
let's move forward and see some popular
machine learning algorithms
some popular machine learning algorithms
are
first one is linear regression algorithm
second one is logistic regression
algorithm
and the third one is decision tree
and the fourth one is support factor
machine algorithm svm
and the fifth one is knn k nearest
neighbor algorithm
the sixth one is k means clustering
algorithms
the and the seventh one is random forest
algorithms
and the last but not the least algorithm
is a priori algorithms let's go through
them in detail one by one
linear regression is one of the most
famous and straightforward machine
learning algorithms utilized for
predictive analysis
linear regression show the linear
connection between the dependent and
independent factors
the equation of line is y equals to m x
plus b
here y stands for the response variable
or a dependent variable whereas x is for
the predictor variable or an independent
variable it attempts best to fit line
between dependent and independent
variables and this best fit line is
known as line of regression or
regression line
let's take a real application example in
predicting consumer behavior businesses
use linear regression to forecast things
like how much a client is likely to
spend
things like targeted marketing and
product development may benefit from
this
walmart for instance use linear
regression to forecast which good would
be in high demand across the nation
moving forward let's see types of linear
regression
there are two types of linear regression
algorithm
the first one is simple linear
regression and the second one is
multiple linear regression in simple
linear regression if an independent
variable is utilized to focus the worth
of a mathematical dependent variable
then at that point such a linear
regression algorithm is called simple
linear regression the equation of line
will be y equals to a 0 plus a 1 x
and the second one is multiple linear
regression if the dependent variable
declines on the y and the independent
variable on the x then such a
relationship is known as negative linear
relationship the line of equation will
be
minus of a 0 plus a 1 x
moving forward let's see logistic linear
regression
logistic regression is the supervised
machine learning algorithm utilized to
anticipate all the categorical factors
or discrete values
it could be very well used for the
grouping issues in learning
and the result of the logistic reaction
can be either yes or no 0 or 1 man or
woman and so on
it gives the values which lies between 0
and 1. for example a credit card
business is interested in knowing
whether the transaction amount and the
credit score have an impact on the
probability that a particular
transaction would be fraudulent
the business can use logitech reduction
to determine how these two predator
values can relate the probability that a
transaction is fraudulent
this response variable in the model has
two possible outcomes
first one is the transaction is
fraudulent and the second one is the
transaction is not fraudulent
in logistic regression rather than
fitting a regression line we fit an s
form logistic capability which predicts
two greatest value zero or 1
the logic regression equation can be
calculated from linear regression
equation the steps to get logistic
regression equations are
the equation of straight line can be
written as
y equals to b 0 plus b 1 x 1 plus b 2 x
2 till b and x n
in logistic regression y can be between
0 and 1 only so for that let's divide
the above equation by 1 minus y
then the equation will be y upon 1 minus
y that is 0 for y 0 and infinity for y
equals to 1 but range between minus
infinity to plus infinity then we have
to take the logarithm of equation and
now it will become log of y upon 1 minus
y equals 2 v 0 plus b 1 x 1 plus b 2 x 2
so on till b and x n
let's move forward and see types of
logistic regression
are three types of logitech regression
that can be classified first one is
binomial in binomial logistic regression
there can be only two possible types of
dependent variables like yes or no pass
of faith man woman and many more and the
second one is multinomial in multinomial
logistic regression there can be three
or more possible unordered ways of
dependent variable such as horse cow and
sheep and the last one is ordinal in
ordinal logistic regression there can be
three or more possible ordered ways of
dependent variable such as small medium
or large moving forward let's see
decision trees in detail
a decision tree is a tree structured
classifier that could be used for
classification and regression a decision
tree is a tree in which each non-leaf
node is assigned to an attribute
additionally each r contain one of the
available values for its parent node
which is associated with each leaf node
that is the node from where the arc is
directed
let's see some decision tree terminology
first one is root that contains the
entire dataset the next one is node
attached for the data of a certain
attribute and the third one is branch
which connect the node to internal node
or the internal node to leaf node and
the fourth one is leaf node the terminal
node that predicts the outcome
let's move forward and see decision tree
algorithms
the first one is select the best
attribute to use the current node in the
tree the second one is for each possible
values select the attributes the third
one is
partition the examples using the
possible values of this attribute and
assign these disjoint subsets of the
example to the appropriate child node
recursively generate each child node
until
ideally all examples for a node have the
same label
like class
moving forward let's understand this
recently
for building a decision tree step one is
select an attribute
then split the data into its children in
a tree continuous plating with available
attributes
and keep splitting until leaf node are
pure like only one class remains a
maximum depth is this a performance
matrix is achieved let's move forward
and see svm algorithm support vector
machine algorithms
a support vector machine is a well
supervised machine learning model it is
utilized for both information
classification and regression
it is regularly utilized for the
grouping issues we can involve it in
different life care system and we can
involve it in typically happy or sad
look arrangements
we can involve it in filters
if we make specific looks
it would add the particular filter
according to the expression
the scope of articulation lies between
happy and sad support vector machine
helps in to recognize handwritten
characters used widely like checks
continue to be a significant part of the
majority of non-cash transaction and are
frequently written by the people
the current check processing system in
many developing nations involves a bank
employee to read and manually enter the
information in a check
while also verifying the data like
signature and date
a handwritten tax recognition system can
reduce expenses and labor hours because
a bank must handle several checks each
day
moving forward let's see the algorithm
of svm
the objective of support vector machine
is to make the best line or choice limit
that can isolate n-dimensional space
into classes
so we can undoubtedly put the new data
of interest in the right category later
on this batch decision boundary is known
as a hyperplane let's move forward and
see types of support vector machine
support vector machine can be of two
types first one is linear svm second one
is non-linear spm let's move forward and
see linear sphere
linear svm is utilized for linearly
detachable information
which implies if a data set can be
ordered into two classes by utilizing a
straight line
that such information are named linearly
separable information and a classifier
is utilized called linear spm classifier
moving forward let's see non-linear sbm
non-linear spm is utilized for
non-directly isolated information and
that implies in the event that a data
set can't be categorized by utilizing a
straight line
such information is named non-directed
information
and the classifier utilized is called a
non-linear svm classifier
moving forward let's see knn algorithm
in detail
knn is a supervised learning technique
knn classifies new data into our
targeted classes depending on the
features of its neighboring points
and also
be used for the regression problems it
is an instance based learning algorithm
and a bit lazy learning algorithm k n
calculation stores every one of its
accessible information and orders
another information point based on the
likeness this means that when new data
information appears it usually tends to
be successfully categorized into a good
suit classes using the canon algorithm
let's imagine we have an image of animal
that resembles a cow or ox however here
we are not sure if it is a cow or ox
as canon method is based on a likeness
matrix it will identify the properties
of new data that are related to the
image of cow or ox
and based on those quality it will
classify the data is belonging to either
cow or ox group
moving forward let's see how does k n
work
the steps to implement k n algorithms
are step one decide on the neighbors k
numbers step 2 calculate the euclidean
distance between k neighbors in step 2.
third one is
based on the determined euclidean
distance select the k closest neighbors
step 4 is count the numbers of data
points in each category between these
key neighbors step 5 assign the fresh
data points in the category where the
highest neighbors count
and then k n model is ready
let's say we need to add a new data
point to the vital category
at first we will decide on the numbers
of neighbors therefore we will pick k
equals to 5
then the euclidean distance between the
data points and then can be determined
the distance between two points known as
the euclidean distance can be determined
by
under root of x 2 minus x 1 whole square
plus y 2 minus y 1 whole square
then we determine the closest neighbors
by calculating the euclidean distance
there are 3 closest neighbors in
category a and two closest neighbor in
category b
this new data point must fall with
category a
because as we can see its three closest
neighbors are also from group a after
understanding knl algorithm let's move
forward and see k-means algorithms in
detail
the k-means is the cluster false under
that is an unsupervised learning
algorithm it is used to address machine
learning clustering problems and utilize
to tackle the grouping issues in machine
learning
it permits us to bunch the information
into various gatherings it is a helpful
method for finding the classification of
groups in the unlabeled data set without
the requirement of any training this
k-means algorithm groups the data into
similar classes let's see some
application of k-means clustering let's
see some applications of k-means
clustering
diagnostic system the medical profession
uses k-means questioning in creating
smarter medical decision support system
especially in the treatment of lever
alignments the second one is search
engines clustering forms a backbone of
search engine when a search engine is
performed the search results need to be
grouped and the search engines very
often use clustering to do this
moving forward let's see how k means
algorithm works
the steps to implement k-means
algorithms are step one select the
number k to set the number of clusters
step two select a random k points or
centroid step three assign each data
point the closest centroid data forms to
predefined k cluster
step four determine the variance and a
certain new gravity points for each
cluster step 5 repeat the third step
this means reallocating each data point
to the new closest centroid cluster
step 6 if a reassignment occurs go to
step 4 otherwise go to exit
step 7 the model is ready to use
so now we have a clear understanding of
how k means algorithm work let's move
forward to see the graphical
representation of k-means algorithm
consider that there are two variables m1
and m2 this is a scatter plot of these
two variables along the x and y axis
we should accept the number of k of
punches that is k equals to 2 to
recognize the data set and to place them
into various groups
it implies here we will attempt to bunch
these data sets into two unique groups
we really want to pick an irregular key
point or centroid to frame this group
these centroids can be either the focus
of the data set or some of other points
thus here we are choosing under two
points as k points which are not the
piece of our data set
we will assign every data of interest in
the scatter plot to the nearest k point
or centroid
we will register it by applying some
math that we consider to find the
distance between two points that is
euclidean distance thus we will draw a
median between both the centroids from
the graph the left half of the line are
close points to the right and the k1
centroid green is near the orange
centroid we should vary them as green
and orange for clear representation as
the need might arise to track down the
nearest group we will repeat the cycle
by picking another centroid
to pick the new centroid we will figure
out the center point of gravity of these
centroids and we'll track down new
centroids then we will reassign every
piece of information to highlight news
android for this we will repeat a
similar course of tracking down a middle
line the middle will be like as seen in
the picture one orange point is on the
left half of the line and two green
points are on the right thus these three
points will be appointed to the new
centroids
as reassignment has occurred we will
again go to step 4 tracking down new
centroids or k points we will repeat the
cycle by tracking down the center point
of gravity of centroid so the new
centroids will be displayed as like this
we now have new centroid so once more
defined the middle boundary and reassign
the data of intros by this graph there
are no unique pieces of information on
one or the other side of the line
implying our model is shaped by the
previous graph there are no unique
pieces of information on one or the
other line
implying our model is shaped
as our k means model is ready and the
two class groups will be displayed as
like these now we have a clear
understanding of how k means clustering
algorithm works now let's move forward
to understand random forest algorithm
random forest is an adaptable simple to
utilize machine learning algorithm that
produces even without the hyper boundary
tuning
an extraordinary outcome more often that
not
it is likewise quite possibly the most
utilized algorithm because of its
effortness and variety like it stands to
be utilized for both grouping and
classification tasks
random forest is a classifier that
contains various choice trees on
different subsets
of the given data set and takes the
normal to work on the present exactness
of the data set instead of depending on
the choice tree the random forest takes
the forecast from each tree and in light
of the larger part of wards of
expectation it predicts the final result
now let's move forward and see how does
random forest work
we should see the random forest in order
since the arrangement is now and again
thought to be the structured block of
machine learning this is what a random
forest would look like with two trees
the random forest has a similar
hypermeter to their decision tree or a
paging classifier luckily there is a
compelling reason need to consolidate a
decision tree with a badging classifier
since you can undoubtedly utilize the
classifier classes of random forest with
random forest you can likewise manage
tasks using the algorithm regressor
random forest add extra bitness to the
model while deploying the trees
rather than looking for the man element
while parting a node
it looks to the best component among an
irregular subset of highlights
these outcomes in a varied variety often
result in a superior model
subsequently in a random forest just a
random subset of the element is thought
about the algorithms you might make
trees more random by involving random
edges
for each component instead of looking
for the most ideal limits like a typical
choice tree does let's move forward and
see some application of random forest
algorithms
random forest is involved at work by
researchers in numerous ventures
including banking stock exchanging
medication and many more it is utilized
to predict things which assist these
businesses with running productively
like client activity patient history and
safety in banking random forest is used
to identify clients who are more likely
to pay back their dabs on schedule
additionally it is utilized to forecast
who will make more frequent use of bank
services even fraud detection uses it
the robber node of algorithms indeed
random forest is a tool used by stock
traders to forecast future stock
behavior
retail businesses utilize it to make
product recommendation and forecast
client satisfaction random forage can be
used in health care industry to examine
a patient medical history and detect
disorders random forest is a tool used
by pharmaceutical experts to determine
the ideal mix of ingredients in
treatment or to forecast drug
sensitivity
by seeing application of random forest
algorithm let's move forward and see
some difference between decision trees
and random forest
let's see the difference between random
forest and decision tree the first one
is while building a random forest the
number of rows is selected randomly
in decision trees it builds several
decision trees and find out the output
the second one is it combines two or
more decision trees together
in decision trees whereas the decision
is a collection of variables or data
sets or attributes the third one is it
gives accurate results whereas it gives
less accurate results the fourth one is
by using random forest it reduces the
chance of overlifting
whereas decision trees it has the
possibility of overlifting
the fifth one is random forest is more
complicated to interpreters whereas the
decision tree is simple it is easy to
read and understand
after seeing what is random forest how
it works let's move forward to see a
priori algorithm in detail
the apparati algorithm utilizes standard
item sets to create affiliation rules
and is intended to chip away the
information bases containing exchanges
with the assistance of these application
rules it decide how firmly or feebly two
objects are associated this algorithm
utilizes a breakfast search and history
to work out the item set association
effectively
it is the iterative interaction for
finding out the successive item set from
the huge data set
let's move forward and see steps for a
priori algorithms the steps for a priori
algorithms are step one is establish
minimal support and confidence for item
set in the transactional database the
second one is take all transaction
supports with a greater support value
the minimum or chosen support value in
step two the third one is track down all
the rules in these subsets with
confidence value creator then the
threshold value the fourth one is
arrange the rules to lower the lift
at last we will see some advantages and
disadvantages of a priori algorithm
the advantages of a priori algorithms
are easy to understand an algorithm and
the second one is the join and prone
steps of the algorithms can be easily
implemented on the large data set
disadvantages of a priori algorithms are
their priority algorithms work slowly as
compared to the other algorithm and the
second one is their priority algorithms
times and space complexity are o of 2d
which is very low compared to the other
ones
let's move forward and see some hands-on
lab demo
so we will see a hands-on lab demo on
linear regression
as we know linear regression is a way to
find or to predict the relationship
between two variables generally we use x
and y
so first we will open command prompt to
write command to open jupyter notebook
so we will write jupiter
notebook
and then press
enter
so this is the landing page of jupyter
notebook and select open
new python file
so this is how jupyter notebook ui looks
like
so at first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
in mathematical functioning so the first
one is numpy
numpy is a python library used for
working with arrays it also has
functions for working in domains like
linear algebra and matrices
it is an open source project and you can
use it freely
numpy stands for numerical python
so we will write like import
numpy
as np
here np is used for denoting numpy
so we will import the next library is
pandas
panda is a software library written for
python programming
for like data manipulation and analysis
in particular it offers data structures
and operation for manipulating numerical
labels and time series
so we will write import
pandas
as pd
here
pd is used for denoting pandas so our
next library is matplotlib
matplotlib is a graph plotting library
in python that serves as a visualization
utility
matplotlib is open source so we can use
it freely and it is most written in
python a few segments in c and
javascript for platform compatibility
for importing metro lib you have to
write import matplotlib
product
dot pi plot
as plt
so after importing the libraries we will
move ahead and import data set so for
importing data set we have to write data
set
equals to pd dot
read underscore
csv
and here we have to give the path of the
file
data set
dot csv
here pd is for pandas library and read
is used for reading the data set from
the machine and csv csv is used for the
type of file which you want to read
so after reading let's see our data so
we will write data set
dot
head
and press enter
here head is used for retrieving the
first file lines from the data so our
data is coming properly so moving ahead
now let's first define x and y axis for
x we have to write x equals to
data set
dot i lock
bracket colon comma
colon again minus 1
dot values for accesses and for y axis
we have to write y equals to
data set
dot i lock
bracket colon comma 1
dot values
so if we will use data set dot i log for
minus 1 values for x axis it will select
till the second last column of the data
frame instead of the last column
and i know this is as the second last
column value and the last column value
for the row is different
whereas if you will use for the y axis
values return a series vector a vector
does not have a column size
so moving ahead let's see the value for
x and y axis first we will see the value
for x
like just you have to write x
and press enter
so
these are the areas value for x
and for y axis you have to type white
and then enter so these are the arrays
value for y axis so after this now let's
split the data set into training and
testing separating data into training
and testing set is an important part for
evaluating data mining models typically
when you separate a data set into a
training set and a testing set most of
the data set is used for training and a
similar portion of data set is used for
testing
so we will split it into 70 and 30 ratio
so for splitting we need to import some
more libraries for this process so we
will write from
sklearn
dot
model
underscore selection
selection
import
train
underscore test
underscore split
scikit learn like sk learn is most
useful and robust library for machine
learning in python it provides a
selection of efficient tools for machine
learning and statical modeling including
classification regression and clustering
so after importing let's write code for
the splitting data so we will write here
x underscore
train
comma
x underscore test
comma y underscore train
comma y underscore
test
equals to
train
underscore test
underscore split
in brackets we have to write x comma y
comma
test
underscores
size
equals to
point three
comma
random
underscore state
equals to zero
random basically
with random state equals to 0 we get the
same trend and test sets across
different execution so after this let's
see the values together
so we will write x underscore train
comma x underscore
test
comma y underscore
train
comma y underscore
test
so these are the values of array x and
array y together moving ahead now let's
work with regression first we need to
import the library for regression so we
will use from
sklearn
dot linear
underscore
model
model
both
linear
regression
we already discussed sqlan is used for
machine learning and linear regression
is a major part of machine learning so
after this let's make a function for
regression as rhg for easy use so we
will write reg
equals to
linear
regression
and brackets
first we try to train and then test and
compare so we will write here
reg
dot
bit
bracket
x underscore
train
comma
y underscore
change
now let's predict values but prediction
values are always different
so
we will predict values for y first so we
will write y
underscore predict
equals to red
dot predict
sorry predict
or x underscore test
so like y underscore
reading
and enter
this is when the predict functions come
into the picture python predict function
enables us to predict the labels of the
data values on the basis of training
model the predict function accept only a
single argument which is x underscore
test here usually the data to be tested
so when you will check the value for y
test you will see the different values
like
white
underscore
test
so you can see there are totally
different values from x axis now let's
display on graph for training data set
so we have to write
plt dot scatter
x underscore train
comma y underscore tray
comma color
equals to
you can choose by yourself i will choose
red
and then plt
dot plot
x underscore train
comma
regression point for predicting values
for x underscore
training
so this color is for the regression line
and the plt dot
versus experience
and i will prefer this size would be
80
so let's set the
labels for x and y axis and
so x label
year of employee
of employee common size will be
i will prefer size will be 50
then
for y-axis we will write
here
like salaries
and i will prefer this same size 15
let's show the plot by writing plt dot
show
then
hopefully we are fortunate everything is
going to be fine
perfect so you can see
we have linear regression line fitting
through our data set so this is how the
linear regression work for training data
set
let's see how it will work for testing
data set
now let's predict for test data set you
can copy for the same and like you can
change it
so we can copy here
so we can paste here
so we have to just change here
into text data set
test here then again
test here
test here
everything everything we will
reduce some size
to
16
let's see
then it will use 12.
so
perfect so you can see we have linear
regression line fitting through our data
set so this is how the linear regression
works for testing data set
this video has introduced you to machine
learning
you realize that machine learning is a
strategy of preparing machine to play
out the exercise a human brain can do
though a bit quicker and better than a
typical person
machine learning can be supervised or
unsupervised
if you have the lesser amount of
information and a name for the preparing
or for supervised learning
unsupervised learning good for the most
part result in better execution and
enormous data sets
we have reached the end of this video i
hope you guys found this video
informative and helpful if you have any
doubts or feedback comments below and
allow us to assist you don't forget to
click the bell icon if you enjoyed the
video and subscribe to our simply learn
youtube channel thank you and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here